In an effort to not have challenging conversations in this day and age.
It's like,
well you do,
you like whatever's best for you.
But then what if best for you is actually harmful to yourself and or others?
Okay,
mine
is a top priority in my life.
You never know
bad.
You feel until you start feeling better than you've ever felt in your life.
And I've been on both ends of the spectrum and down.
It's very different to now being like really focused on the mind,
body and soul and like really having all parts just as equal as the other.
For me,
I am as cancer survivor and so my entire life now is about making sure that I
have a life,
you know,
to continue.
So yeah,
I was diagnosed with lymphedema at age three which affects the circulation for
me through my legs and feet.
So health for me has always been at the top of my mind because if I don't take
care of my body,
like I could have an amputated foot or leg.
So it's nothing that I play around with
all of my family,
almost his suffer from diabetes,
heart disease and stuff like that.
So that's why I'm extra conscious about my health because I don't want to come
down with any of those diseases.
Ah,
I'm working out consistently since I was 19 years old.
I used to work out two hours a day,
but then I realize it's way too long.
So now my workout session with weights are about 45 minutes and then the rest is
stretching and cardio and I spent a lot of time stretching because it allows me
to get in the zone,
kind of like a meditation of sorts.
It's all mental,
like I go to the gym or workout or do something kind for my body in forms of
movement every day because it keeps me sane.
Like if I don't go there,
then I feel like something's missing and I get a little bit depressed.
Okay.
Singing all by myself back there.
I was going to the gym regularly every day for like six months and then my life
shifted.
I lost my father.
Like lot of things happened in my life is that um,
threw off my whole routine.
And so the point when,
when I was going to the gym so regularly I felt like my brain felt happier.
Like I've gotten that feeling back in other ways.
I have no desire in me to change my body in any way.
I like my buckets a little bit.
Right.
Okay.
Not at all.
See this is where we're going to get because I will tell you not every big
person wants to be
mom.
I am conscious
my mom had any weight watchers in junior high.
Like so my relationship with food and what I'm putting into my body has been
like completely can we curse fucked up like since the very,
very big headaches of your sugar addiction since I was a kid.
And it's like the binge eating,
like it makes you feel like everything,
I can't have this,
this is the enemy.
So when I see it and I can have it,
I'm like oh I want to eat it all.
Okay.
Every day I wake up,
I have a green smoothie.
I'm always very conscious of like what I'm putting into,
which I think is,
I'm just gonna say the controversial statement I think is something that people
would never think is true based off the size of my body and there's so much
studies that are coming out like in terms of like your microbiome,
like the micro biome that you have.
Like you can literally eat green smoothies and eat like everything you're
supposed to be eating and not lose the weight because we have an imbalance in
your microbiome and like,
and then people who are thin,
they just really thin but they eat McDonald's every day.
Yep.
They don't realize is how much they're clogging their arteries and they die of
heart attacks more than quote unquote big
people.
I receive negative feedback.
There you go.
I would have people,
like some family members be like,
oh you look a little heavier than you did last year.
And then other family members that were a lot more direct like,
oh,
when are you going to lose the weight?
And it's been like that.
I would say my whole life.
And then we got to a point where I was getting compared to my little sister
who's like beautiful and thin and it's like,
it is so hard not to compare yourself to other people.
It is so hard to have a healthy relationship with food and with fitness and just
with other people in.
It became so difficult to break out of that and to really love who I am inside.
Right?
My step mom would take,
like if I had a wrapper of chips,
like in my room,
like she would put it on top of like Mike,
my dresser and say like,
I'm off the reason why you're fat,
it's this.
It was like,
it was all very light,
but it was super crazy psychological because I was like,
we've never even discussed this before.
I'm from Texas,
we all eat soul food,
so everybody's eating the same shit food.
So my mom,
250 pounds,
my brother,
350 pounds,
but I saw I was eating the exact same foods and I didn't even know until I got
around Los Angeles health conscious people.
I'm like,
what?
What do you mean to tell me you don't have fricking Bacon cheeseburger every
single day?
I didn't know.
So like when you got until they,
what triggered it in your head that said,
oh this to me is the right way for me to like I want it to be a model.
The idea that you wanted to become a model and the only idea of model to you
mapping thin or fit or whatever.
That beat me
all I saw because it wasn't as popular like plus size wasn't popular back then
when I was 18 yes,
results definitely now,
but it's still,
it's still opened up way more than it was.
The conversation I will say is much more broad now.
I feel like we're able to talk about these things a lot easier now than we were
before,
but what the actual way that the industry treats plus size models is totally
different.
Yeah.
As an excuse not to here.
This question makes me a very passionate,
this is really big for me because I've been like come for from other body
positive influencers,
but I feel like the messages other people put out are very dangerous to a young
woman who thinks that it's okay.
I don't care what size you are,
it's not okay to sit and eat cheeseburgers and ice cream all day like that has
nothing to do with your size.
Yeah.
I think there's a difference between acceptance and agreement.
So like you can accept your body and be in disagreement with the health
situation that you have.
Right.
We hear fit experts always saying be skinny,
lose weight.
That's the healthy way to do it.
Like so how can we have your body,
your families,
we don't say be fat because it's better for your heart.
It's,
it's better for your soul.
It's better for your to say even what you just said,
like body acceptance versus body agreement.
Like to you.
You might see one of us
be like,
oh they love their except their bodies,
but I'm sure they don't agree with what it looks like.
I mean,
I wouldn't know unless I talked with someone,
but like,
like whatever the number,
like whatever like is coming up in terms of like,
you know,
when you go to the doctor like that the other day,
it's not even Steven better as fit people.
When you see a person who is overweight or fat or obese,
however you want,
whatever term you wanna use,
what's the first thing happens in your head?
Did you think?
Like,
oh,
like it's great that they accept themselves but they could use to lose weight or
what is your first thought?
First.
Dot.
No,
no one's like born that way.
So you,
you liked there's habits and things that you observed
but you actually can be born with that.
I like eat the exact same thing and it can be two different people.
How you're raised parenting and stuff like that.
Um,
I didn't really know what to expect today.
I didn't know how the body positive individuals we're going to come across.
I didn't know if they were for healthy lifestyle or not,
but I think it's beautiful that you guys acknowledge how important it is to keep
yourself healthy.
Do I feel like there are people in the body positive community that say,
well I'm just happy being fat and I'm just going to lay down and just do that?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
You Ha I fat pride Hashtag fat pride is like was something that was going on.
It's like a while.
Yeah.
Big Buzzword.
Everyone just throws out like you said something at some point that Bazi body
positivity and like health and stuff is different.
Like is that one everybody thinks the actual body positive community was created
to give a platform to bodies that have been marginalized in our society.
That's what it was actually created for big bodies,
disabilities,
any Bonnie Raitt different races and I want to scream because I'm like,
actually this is not meant for you.
This is meant for bodies who,
who don't have a voice.
The fitness community is the reason why the buys are body positive.
Community exists.
And I think that as a community it's important
for you guys to be a little bit more inclusive.
People come up to me,
it was really great talking to you guys or not.
I think we really did find a middle ground.
Um,
but we did.
I think we all realize it.
It's like not,
it's not,
this line isn't alive.
Pride and ego out.
Let's Friggen,
no,
I love how the actual line it was actually on this side.
Hey guys,
Jason from jubilee here.
We hope you enjoyed another episode of middle ground.
Honestly,
this is one of our favorite series,
the making and we hope you enjoy it too.
Let us know in the comments below what you think about this issue and if you
agree or disagree with anyone,
um,
as always,
make sure you click here to subscribe.
Click here for more videos,
follow
Instagram and we will see you guys later.